what do you get if you cross Braveheart
with a pudding bowl that's right you get
Nicholas sturgeon and just like
Braveheart Nicola only really had one
plan which was to scream the word free
them and get defeated by the English in
every important battle to be fair to
helmet head she's had some brilliant
ideas trans women are women particularly
when there are double rapist with a
tribal face tattoo and leggings that
show off his shapely clitoris people
will point to your incompetent handling
of the pandemic the Scottish economy
being in tatters and excess deaths going
through the roof but we all know the
real reason why you quit you picked a
fight with Scottish women and that was
never going to end well there's a reason
why the Romans built Hadrian's Wall and
left them to it they took one look at
the women and thought we've had taken on
her number and his army but there's no
way we're going to go against the Mora
against six of our sisters especially
when they've been on the whiskey